Harris changed his camera
we are live
welcome to soundtrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel and we are
we have many guests we're surrounded by
guests
we have Aaron
I'm chilling in the basement
um I was on your channel last week and
now it's your turn we have Matthew it
was our little side Trek buddy and we
have Young Harris the baby of the bunch
uh
also an American
why do we do this why do we do this
um
and welcome to live soon I say hello
everybody how you all doing okay
hello there
hello
uh before we get started first of all we
have to do our branding thing we'll have
to do the little uh intro so it is
[Music]
okay I still love that intro but I
thought it was going to be the Stargate
one I was really excited for a second
yeah yeah I know it's well with anything
and now before we get into anything else
before we start talking about
Mandalorian today we do have Stargate
news
exciting like I'm in my London Studio
the desk and everything but anyway the
big news
I've got a movie I've got a video coming
out Tuesday it's going to have a lot
more detail in this but basically the
news is we are going to be getting a
movie in a TV series these have already
been basically green lit and they will
be announced into uh June mid-june this
is going to be basically a negotiation
Michael Wright who is the head of MGM
plus currently was dead set against an
initial movie he has now agreed that a
movie is the best way to go and we're
going to be getting that as long with
the TV series I can also confirm that
they are currently looking for a
director and I've already spoken to a
couple of people and if that's not
enough we're also going to be getting
well we've also heard that there is an
initial script that's been completed by
Mark Fergus and that that is currently
back with MGM to be having a look at so
we have a script they're looking for a
director and they're going to be
announcing the movie in the series very
very soon
did somebody
carry on with their own thing with the
because the noise you weren't muted
Maybe
released but anyway guys so that's
that's the big news we're going to be
doing it every week hopefully when we've
got somebody to say but that's the big
news it does look like mid-june when we
hit this
um I think it's like San Diego Comic Con
they're going to be announcing not just
a movie but a TV series
Matt what's your initial reaction to
that news
[__] yeah
yeah
how about you Aaron do you think before
I go to you that's all you get that's
all you get
you're not allowed to say anything else
Aaron what do you think sir
oh sorry my apologies um we rhyme it
does Aaron is one of those names I never
thought would confuse me but it legit
does sometimes it is fun yeah but no
that's that I mean I personally prefer a
series first but that is fantastic news
I I'm very excited for an official
announcement coming like Stoke I'm
wearing a Star Wars shirt today because
you know the title but
I've been waiting for Gig forever but
just like you guys so I am very much
here for it and as they say where I'm
from a Metro Detroit
how about you ask what you're thinking
yay I'm pumped I'm just uh you know I'm
a Star Wars guy like nobody's business
so I'm on a Star Wars mindset but the
one thing that's taken me out of a Star
Wars mindset recently of course is I'm
still watching Stargate Atlantis still
mid season four but I'm playing Deadeye
Survivor right now it'll break attack
himself is like the Masters Master he's
he's completely one of the parts of both
those games and it makes me so [__]
happy sorry I use my curse word but I
try to go a little louder with it uh but
no I'm I'm ecstatic for it like like
Aaron said I'd probably prefer a series
first
but I'm not opposed to a movie at all
we've gone through all the different
scenarios and I really think a movie is
just as applicable and uh potentially
better in the sense of getting new
viewers on board uh
it it does put us in a precarious
position if it's got to be good it's got
to be good but
if more more people come in it is good
it's a win-win you know so I think this
idea that because from what I've Been
Told
Matt Ryan certain other people the MGM
this is focus mainly in MGM really we're
pushing hard for a series and Jennifer
salkid head of um MGM pictures now and
Amazon pictures basically listen to what
they're saying and I think maybe even
they heard us not specifically us but
maybe even they had the same thinking
that if the movie doesn't do great
what's gonna happen to the series so
they've just sort of gone well let's
just do both
I've got a video that's going to be on
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
immediately after this and it'll go live
on YouTube on Tuesdays talk in a bit
more detail about that
um but to me a lot of the risk is gone
if they're going to do both
what's the matter it's just the movies
for the series
I did have a question about it you said
Mark Fergus has written the script is
that for the movie or the TV show do we
know I'm here in the movie script
there's been they've got a very early
version of the movie script
um
Fergus is involved yes I've actually
said that wrong sorry because I've wrote
mukford's name underneath and then put a
question mark and I've read it wrong
when I was doing it right that's not
what I was told
um we don't know if Mark Fergus wrote it
or not right okay so that's the problem
so the the scriptures come through and
the guy actually said to me specifically
that I was speaking to actually said
um we don't know who wrote it
and that's a bit concerning because the
whole penguin in a park I think seems to
go a bit quiet but I'm going to I've got
a couple of other people I need to speak
to that I haven't I haven't got through
to yet
um that hopefully will give us very very
quick however it's come about maybe it's
a script they already had that that's
what I was thinking did they just use
the Brad script in that case because
that's the only thing they like legit
just have on hand yeah or at least three
quarters of the Brad script parts of the
Brad script the context on a script to
hell they could just make some mobs from
whichever ones they've already got
they need the speed at which
I wasn't expecting a script to have been
done already
sharing that is
about 40 pages I I think a good writer
if they knew what they were going for
but it's a good thing is Mark Fergus has
had this if it's Mark Fergus it's wrote
it
he's had this bounce around in his head
for nine months nearly so it's been and
but I'm told it's an early first draft
of something so
all right I don't think that the timing
is is a major issue
um and it's from what I'm told about
Mark Fergus is the man is um is a
workaholic he apparently works to like
he just writes constantly so it doesn't
really surprise me but it's been done if
if that's if he's done it so
um yeah so
looking for a director
I think I think if they're looking for a
director this these plans are relatively
far along as well
um I haven't got any games yet but I'll
hopefully get some names as soon as I
try but
it's interesting let's see what happens
let's see what happens
at least we're getting movement
yeah
it feels like things are solidified
slightly we're getting
noise that makes sense and it's
consistent the rumors are getting more
consistent we're not getting variations
of things going on which we we've got
before like Star Trek at the moment the
rumors are all over the bloody place you
know there's like
this is happening this is happening this
is happening and with Stargate at the
moment it seems it's consistent you know
it's like it's all gone in One Direction
so
and then it'll all bloody change
um if we get the highlights from this
we've got the Stargate movie coming
first TV series to follow an
announcement by did you say June or July
June but I just then said July because
I'm an idiot because I forgot June
I will prepare for that News segment a
little bit better next time
I threw myself I could hear you guys
knit through me I'm preparing for making
the tick tock version of this
announcement so okay good man good night
okay so yeah but that is that's where
we're looking at so it'll be San Diego
Comic Con so just double check the the
dates but I'm pretty sure it's mid-june
there is one little thing going on
though and this is like the main subject
of my stream last night is that we're
gonna have no Writers come Tuesday
it's very possibly
that's almost guaranteed from what I've
been seeing so it's I think it's most
likely right strike and it is true that
I mean I've got a couple of videos
coming this week that I've already
recorded talking about the writer's
strike noise the main reason why this
hasn't been announced yet is because the
right to strike the main reason Babylon
5 hasn't been announced is the right to
strike
um and yeah
um
all the studios are focused around
getting everything done anything that's
even in early pre-production get the
[__] scripted just get them done so
that we can carry on filming if the
strike happens so we're not just
shutting down so
you know it's that that's a that's a big
big problem at the moment
um but well no well no Tuesday yeah
I still think it's a 50 50 chance I
really don't think it's gonna end up
happening just just from just from being
out in like Los Angeles and just seeing
people and stuff i i i i people want to
get paid even though they can't agree
what they want to be paid
immediately they want to get paid
nonetheless and a strike does not get
them paid so
I I think
it's still kind of 50 50. hopefully not
I'm being optimistic here Harris what do
you think about this idea that um it was
potentially actually I don't think I've
released the video yet
okay and the video that's going to be
released the next day or two I talk
about an idea that I was told by a guy
that's um he's a writer and there's this
genuine belief that they think the
writer's Guild believe that actually the
alliance of producers Etc want the
strike to happen because a lot of the
studios want to cancel projects but they
want to do it without looking stupid so
they can if they can do it and blame the
writers
all the better and that they want to
squeeze the deal as much as possible to
save money is that that that to me seems
cut your nose off to spite your face
sort of planning do you think that's
even remotely likely
I mean there's always Studio politics
happening on happening in the background
and like what what are we looking at
with Disney cutting down even their the
two biggest IPS in the world right now
Star Wars or Marvel they're cutting
those down significantly all these other
studios are Warner Brothers has become
much more specific with what they green
light thankfully uh for for their Max uh
prescription or subscription not
prescription of course uh
yes and no I'm leaning heavily towards
both as in it's it's happening but I
don't know if it's like that that's not
like the primary reason that's
definitely a reason for the Riders to be
like
yeah okay don't don't use us as a
scapegoat
at the same time people want a paycheck
so we'll see what the vote happens on
Tuesday you know
the strike's already been approved with
like a 98 vote
there's already footage out there then
putting their signs together and um
one of the oh
oh one of the things that um I think is
on the writer side is they're very
worried about AI That's one of their
things they want to make sure they want
to make sure if a story they come up
with gets fed into an AI they still get
their money for coming up with the story
in the first place and right now there's
no nothing really in place for that for
them so they came up with a really great
thing though for it right the writer's
Guild
uh yeah one of their one of their
proposals I think is really good for it
but um actually one of the really fun
rumors and I got and to give credits do
a lot of what I uh covered last night
what I'm going to talk about right now
came from the hot mic podcast with uh
John Rogan and Justin Schneider
um but one of the very more roomy rumery
let me be clear rumoring things is that
uh on the producer side Netflix is the
one holding things up
boom
okay well they spend a crap load of
money so I think that's just they don't
want to be clear evidently they don't
want to be clear about a where that
money goes and B their actual streaming
numbers
Guild wants a lot more transparency when
it comes to that basically so they make
so they can make sure they're getting
paid fully for their work yeah and
allegedly which is main sticking points
Netflix for trying to protect the
numbers as much as possible they do not
like releasing that sort of data do they
at all so what do you think
it's a bit crazy yeah I mean the amount
of strikes that are going on now just
around the world I mean I've I'm not
going to be surprised if it goes ahead
but I work in education like there's
strikes every other week now we had one
last what Thursday we've got another one
Tuesday
so I mean uh yeah I reckon it's gonna
happen but yeah hopefully hopefully the
scripts and stuff that we want to come
out will have been done before that and
we can we can still get what we want but
um I wouldn't be surprised if it
happened essentially yeah we don't need
any more delays
right anyway we are here to talk about
Star Wars and
um well specifically the Mandalorian
season three so I've got a list of
things that I
um
didn't really like during Mandalorian
season three I think it's fair to say
hey little grogu little Stone
um my first thing on my list and about
that I actually really disliked about
the Mandalorian series but we'll get
into
the overall feel in the series was um
robogro
and it wasn't really going to serve much
of a purpose and then he saves like
mando
essentially and I was like oh okay
they've made grogu actually useful now
so yeah sideline the whole season for
the most part yeah
especially that Viral clip of the
anzelan which was great
yeah sorry buddy you're not the first
one in a big Disney IP to be dropping an
F-bomb
Marvel didn't get it but the anzelan did
exactly
[Music]
I was watching Robo grogu the whole time
and I was just thinking
from [__] Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles that's all that's all
I just thought it was so stupid but what
did you guys generally think of the
Season particularly compared to Seasons
uh Matt what's what what's your first
instinct we'll start with you
there were elements of it that were
boring I would say boring
um like there were episodes that just
didn't need to happen uh if if they
weren't in the series or you could
essentially miss them and the story
would still make sense uh uh overall
I quite enjoyed it having my Gideon come
back great I love that character uh I
can't remember the guy's name but
essentially gossfring whoever he is I
love that guy so him coming back great
I'm expecting him to come back in season
four even though you know he's
he will he will you know
um yeah I mean it was all it's not I
preferred season two
season one was all right because I I
watched
um I completely skipped out the season
one when it first come out so I watched
season one and two at the same time and
I really like season two
uh uh I I don't think season three is as
strong a season two at least for me but
it was still enjoyable
fair enough
I thought it was crap uh Aaron what do
you think overall what do you think
particularly like compared to one or two
oh no sorry can I come here
Jack Black
[__] Jack Black being Jack Black next
to [__] lizzo
yeah that was great oh that was amazing
though why did they drop Jack Black in
that episode and Christopher Lloyd
I don't know oh my God it was over the
Run of cameos for me I was like why did
you do it in the same episode it was
cool I loved that Jeff blackface and
everything but it was cool but anyway
Aaron what did you think
um compared to seasons one this is a
week of season of the three easily like
easily with the weakest um season one
was
really really good season two was epic
and this season was just
it started off all right I enjoyed the
first couple episodes like a lot and
then they then there was the whole okay
here's what happened to Pershing in the
middle of actual Story episode
and then a couple more fillers including
the Jack Black and lizzo episode which
while cute was a complete freaking waste
of time
those like that episode for me like the
last 10 minutes was the only thing that
actually made sense in that whole
episode uh so overall I would give this
season probably like a seven
come up to me honest that's
average is six generally speaking so
seven
okay I'd give it a three how about you
house what did you think I don't like
it's it's my least favorite season
but I loved it
that being said
it's my Star Wars loving heart that
loved it it's I've watched all the Clone
Wars I've watched tales of the Jedi I've
watched Rebels and I've watched all of
them half a dozen times because they
came out in my childhood and I've grown
alongside them and yada yada so I got
Star Wars down mentally you know so that
part of the season was amazing for me
this Star Wars Concepts coming to live
action a lot of the things that I've
been wanting to see since I was
nine ten years old on the big not the
big big screen but a big enough screen
that was only like two years ago Harris
2021 something like that
uh I'll be jealous because grow a better
beard then okay
but yeah but but uh
objectively speaking
it's not quality television in the same
sense that the first two seasons were
and that being said I'm being objective
with the first two seasons I adore those
and it's got like I would say season one
and two are both like eight and a half
nine out of tens for me
but
they're really freaking simple and this
follows that formulaic pattern of being
really like super simple I know people
say that about Mandalorian all the time
but I think it really came to a head
with this season obviously grogu they
didn't know what to do with grogu I
didn't think grogu was gonna be in this
season and it didn't seem like he really
was written to be and it seemed like he
was just going to pass back in there
that could be a bunch of Studio politics
in the background that that could be a
whole different conversation
but
I still like what we got
above a surface level if that makes
sense I don't know I I'd love to say a
seven I don't know if I'd go six I'd
give it a six and a half seven still I
like that range just because it really
does bring a lot of things that are
necessary for Star Wars to have in live
action in live action like like Boca tan
Katie sack off anything just first of
all I I grew Teddy sack off she's our
sci-fi Queen you know I love her to
death I watch anything and everything I
watched another life with her on Netflix
and that wasn't all I did but it was
still fun with her
um but she needed to be in my position
but I love her very very much yeah did
y'all hear about that one I'm definitely
a two percenter oh yes and just like
Christian Harlock said right after it's
much higher than two percent oh
much higher than two percent uh
but uh yeah Bo needed to come to live
action we needed to see the dark saber
and more of just uh a McGuffin kind of
way and we we needed to I mean it's not
we didn't need all this but I like me
some drasticy kind of things I like
seeing all the giant dinosaurs pop up
and all that kind of cool stuff if they
formulate it uh to the story a little
better instead of like okay it's at the
beginning of a thing or it's at the end
and it's just like you know it's very
formulaic in the way they present it to
us and I think that's what we're growing
tired of I don't think it's the content
or or I don't like even saying the word
content unless we're talking like a
YouTube kind of thing uh but I
I don't think it's that the the project
itself Mandalorian is going downhill per
se I think there's a lot of politics
going on in the background and this was
uh
uh us
even like your average Star Wars fan or
your average fan that just watches Mando
or or anything this is where they're
kind of like okay that's Star Wars
politics in the background is BS because
it's affecting what we're watching more
so than just like
all right this is It's a
I'm not speaking super low right here go
on a tangent but it's it's not just the
movies it's the TV series and it's
culminating where like it's affecting
Star Wars as a whole or the sequel
Trilogy was further away and there were
a lot of people that didn't like it and
that's because of the writing and a lot
of the studio politics behind that but
TV's kind of been the safe spot for
years and now that it's Bridging the Gap
between the sequels and that it's
definitely
losing that safe spot and that's what we
just witnessed that that was all a
season three of Mando I think uh for
better and worse how much of it is a
problem though is that between them
filming this
and Mandalorian season and then it
actually airing that that is when they
decided to do a massive shake-up with
their plans for Star Wars there were
elements within this series that are now
irrelevant because they were setting up
things that now aren't going to happen
which you know better than I do but how
much of a problem was that I don't I
don't think that's a problem because if
you watch the Clone Wars or Rebels or
anything like that Dave filoni is I know
favro is technically the Mandalorian guy
but filoni's the creative director of
Lucasville now he's
supersedes even Star Wars so he's on
board with everything and and has a
certain way of doing things if you watch
Clone Wars particularly uh it took three
not not three episodes or not two or
three arcs of episodes it took three
years for people to like the Ahsoka
character and there's a reason it's
she's so beloved and brought to live
action now uh even though she's a very
difficult character to bring to live
action have two lightsabers swing around
with two giant uh Lexus on her head it's
a whole different thing to film live
action but there's a reason they brought
her you know uh
yeah no that's done that's that was
actually also part of what was wrong
with uh this season of the Mandalorian
is they were 100 they had to they were
attempting to cram like some of that off
the wall crap
that was in a lot of these episodes was
them attempting to cram some of the
Rangers of the new Republic storyline in
that they couldn't use because they
fired Gina who was supposed to be the
leader Rangers in the Republic it was
supposed to be her and um
what's the X-Wing Pilot's name uh Carson
tiva yeah it was supposed to be her
Rangers in the public was supposed to be
her and Carson TiVo working together
yeah and when they fired her that series
went out the window so they crammed a
couple three storylines from that into
the Mandalorian
yeah we weren't supposed to have like
the the Imperial spy lady that was moff
Gideon's kind of uh spy in the new
Republic or Pershing or or Carson tiva
maybe Carson tiva going to hang out with
the mandalorians for a little oh so that
that was leading up to this series that
didn't come out it's not going to come
out because I I watched that and I I was
although it it was a good episode I
didn't think it fitted
but now that you said that now it makes
sense it's piecemeal just put together
puzzle piece together uh as best they
could kind of it's not puzzle pieced
it's Frankenstein together after the
fact they're like okay reshoot work
around it kind of works put it out you
know uh
how was you mentioned earlier
um about the form formulaic like how it
comes across yes
season three for me
with the first episode I felt that 100
like it was very very formulaic and I
didn't like that they keep it I don't
like I like TV shows that follow a
formula
but I don't like it when it's a very
obvious formula and they just do the
same thing over and over and over again
but that is the way so but there's rides
a little bit better and make it so I
don't notice it because essentially the
formula is we need this oh side quest
and they go on the side quest and I was
I was watching like the first episode oh
he's going on another side quests like
it didn't season one like I did in
season two
I bet there's going to be something that
happens on that side quest and it's
going to lead on to another side quest
oh I was right like just make it a
little bit better
case in point for that was what Aaron
was saying just a minute ago was the the
and what you were mentioning was Jack
Black and lizzo as as fun as it is and
they do well for a general audience just
to kind of bring people in yeah
the last two minutes of that episode it
was the only like actual meet you know
everything else was just fat hanging off
and in great flavor delicious but we
needed we need the meat we want our
proteins
and he was like all right we'll put you
in Star Wars there's an episode awesome
that first episode part of the
awkwardness of that first episode is the
fact that they had to basically cover
for those who didn't watch the book of
Boba Fett why the hell grogu was even
back
Tatooine for five minutes just for the
sake of it just like yeah they had to
they had to bring them back to Navarro
so he could explain why grogu was back
and you know of course they had to set
up the land that they used later and all
that stuff but yeah they for because the
book of Boba Fett was nowhere near as
likely washed as Mando they had to
unless unless you were like a nerd you
really didn't most people didn't know
that grogu was
hanging out with Luke in a couple
episodes of book of boba and then it
came back to him so they had to explain
that
to quite a few people so that that's why
that's something that wasn't as popular
I I really enjoyed book of it
especially the middle when it was
Mandalorian 3.5 yeah that was a lot of
it those were the best two episodes of
the season was when it was like the
mandrel ones but those really shouldn't
have happened
I nearly stopped watching Mandalorian
first two episodes of the first season I
was like God this is slow
um and then I got into it and I really
enjoy it but I don't get excited I felt
like that on the first season
the first season yeah the first season I
watched it and yeah
I watched the first two episodes start
watching it and then we'll head back to
it and watched it again I was like give
it a go same thing he kept me going was
I was like I've got a Sci-Fi channel
I've really got to watch this
and then I started I I got it and I
started to enjoy it and you know and um
but yeah I don't hate Star Wars I was
just always tracking when I was a kid so
it's hard for me to
it's it's different isn't it and it's
like I'm more of a Trekkie so I struggle
with at times but no I no I I will tip
my hat to you guys you guys actually
know what you're talking about on this
one
right well I don't I'm a general fan
these two
idiots
that also screwed up this season I mean
just for foreign politics
there's I still want to get hired by
Disney y'all
like I wouldn't worry about it
working at Lucasville might be fired the
same day because I just walk into
Kathy's office and defenestrator see ya
fair enough
go on that what about the politics
well again this is you know coming from
insiders is a bit rumery but um like we
were talking about earlier it was
basically Kathy that forced the whole
grogu thing
back that soon and a lot of it probably
well a lot of it also has to do with why
they changed the uh the premise of the
window off movie and well changed
lindeloff to Steven Wright it's Mark
it's marketing and product grogu sells
yeah uh Young
Ray sells I don't know if you guys heard
about the original premise to the window
off movie but
it got changed a lot
like a lot a lot like lendloff wanted to
said it 60 years after rise of Skywalker
so he was looking to cast like a Helen
Mirren type to play an old Ray and then
she was going to find a couple young
Force users and train to be Jedi and you
know set things right in the Galaxy yada
yada the usual but that was his original
pitch which Kathy approved until she saw
the script and then she's like nah
bounced him for Steven Wright and was
like all right I need a younger ring for
whatever reason
able the the the the news 20 25 movies
are coming out yeah yeah this is for the
2025. the next one to come out
yeah
supposedly is that is that going to be
what yeah young Ray so what when she's
it's gonna be like seven years after the
after rise instead they they said 15.
how we got young Leia that kind of thing
she's 15 years older than where the rise
of Skywalker ends is where the next
movie is going to pick up basically so
they could keep days oh so it's after
what we've seen yeah oh okay okay I'll
I'll focus on the other way around this
movie was always going to be set after
rise of Skywalker but Lindelof wanted to
set it 60 years after right yeah Kathy
was after I mean she approved the
initial premise but I guess the script
wasn't that great and she had second
thoughts like I don't know if we can
really sell older Ray let's get Daisy
back and just make it like 10 to 15
years after I guess 15 years after now
so at the moment so the the the they do
keep jumping through time and for it for
somebody like me who will watch it and
enjoy Star Wars but isn't the Avid fan
you two guys are it's hard to know
what's going on I got you know I'll I'll
go right okay this is this point in Star
Wars after the thing but before or that
thing and then oh gosh okay which time
frame is this now and then a great
example of that when that came out was
the easiest for me
no for me it wasn't when it first come
out I I assumed it was a new movie
coming out and I just didn't get it and
then and then someone was like oh no
this is set between uh was it except
just before A New Hope isn't it
essentially yeah and then I was like oh
so it's between a New Hope and return
the whatever that prequel third degree
was called yes okay yeah
um and then to be honest
um and or sort of confused me because I
had to you know I just I'm like writing
notes trying to figure out the time
frame for andal like how far before was
it and it's before this so I mean
so I can understand why somebody at
Disney might have gone let's not do the
next Trilogy 60 years ahead I'm confused
even more people let's get it so it's
roughly
chronologically sort of like where we
would be so it's going to be is it five
years in Skywalker now or will it be by
the time the movie comes out it'll be
right in 15 years I mean actually
literally from when Skywalker came out
was it was it 2020 or something like
that
and then it'll be 20 20. so six years
Gap but it's 15 years in the movie
that's not a big you know what I mean
that's that's chronologically not that
far off it won't come through the wider
audience maybe are they also making one
that is set like five six hundred years
in the past
actually if it's if it's going exactly
by the title it's more like twenty
thousand yeah because it's like the the
the how the Jedi Order became the Jedi
Order essentially yeah yeah it's gonna
be set on typhoon which is the planet
that grogu they had to take rogu to for
him to summon whoever he was going on
the big glowy rock all right
in a time a long long long long time ago
okay see as um see okay Disney hire me
I'm I'm on your side for this one for
once uh but
I I feel like KK did do the right thing
there uh because if we're doing the
James Mangold going back to the way
before like even the Old Republic we're
already gonna get that a little bit
harder sci-fi because there's only one
thing to do with the first first user
first Jedi I mean he's creating a
religion you're you're putting rules to
the things that we see as fantasy magic
jargon uh which makes it more hard
sci-fi compared to the space fantasy
that we're used to and and that coming
from James Mangold I'm okay with that
Damon Lindelof 100 would have gone the
same way I love Linda Loft with Watchmen
and all these different type of things
that's just kind of the way he does
things I love that trippy kind of let's
really spin this in a whole different
way we didn't expect but I can see where
Kathleen Kennedy is looking at because
if she changed all of Mandalorian in
season three just to put grogu back in
she wants those uh
Kathleen Kennedy's a good producer she
she knows money and and she knows what
your average Joe wants and I think
that's where she's going with that and I
I don't blame her in this instance for
this if that makes sense
of reaction I saw there was a lot of
people that would would have preferred
lindelof's script because there's a
large portion of the fan base that would
love more separation from the sequels
rather than less yes but like Jay said I
feel like that's that's the core fan
base and and I'm 100 part of that I
would I much prefer Linda Lofts I I I I
would I just love his writing style I
like Stephen Knight I haven't even
watched peaky blinders though so I
haven't watching blinders is
magnificent we're from we're from up the
road Matt is from even closer to me
where are the haircuts but we live
within a stone stripe of peaky blinders
so that's uh
you you might know the answer to this so
on on on the
like the the prequel that's coming like
from like 20 000 years in the past I've
read a little bit about Star Wars
history and how they had their old
lightsabers they had Proto Savers that
had a thing on the back
is that gonna do you reckon that's gonna
be in that I don't think so but please
please please Disney we we've we've been
nice
I don't know the time frames at all as
to how when they went from that to like
properly so there's two ways that can go
they I don't think they're gonna go
proto-saver I don't even think I don't
think they're gonna go lightsaber I
don't think they're going lightsaber at
all I think they're using proso Savers
saver yeah it'd be regular swords and
things like that but Force imbued if
that makes sense if you watch the Clone
Wars a lot of the times and I guess no
they haven't really done any live action
I don't think Knight sisters or Knight
Brothers really Darth Maul's the closest
we've gotten to that
yeah that is gonna change the game
that's gonna change the game entirely uh
on the way we view Star Wars in a lot of
ways it's gonna be fun
okay yeah but um if they're sticking to
the Legends novels about the dawn of the
Jedi you know
quick side note back then they were the
Jedi j-e-d-a-i-i
um they use Force imbued Steel weapons
basically forced microwave knives than
vipro swords essentially is what that
boils down to
it was actually in Legends Sith that
invented the lightsaber
and then and then Disney are well known
for not [__] with Canada
thankfully with this
we have creative director Dave filoni on
board that's that is the Saving Grace
that I he he's so anal about lore and
and well okay that's not actually he's
not anal about Lord because yeah he'll
toss it out but whenever he does pick
what is lore he sticks with it I guess
uh but it's very much live action I
didn't expect him to go the way he did
because he's even changed some things
he's done an animation uh which is like
his pet projects his babies you know but
uh if he puts in a live action I think
that is like that that is the canonical
thing that we're supposed to think about
so the the deciding factories whether
they can create some sort of toy that
they can sell of a force imbued
lightsaber
if they can't but I say what's
something like you hit a button in the
handle and it vibrates you're good there
it is force imbued sword I know certain
people will love that oh and yes
especially if you plug it in I love it
um but yeah okay let's go back in season
three
where's your mango
yeah uh I don't know um I was on the
washing machine I was having a moment
yeah
um was Mandalore in season three a
missed opportunity to understand the
Mandalorian culture better because for
me as I get an outsider again a little
bit um it was confusing
or did you do we think we learned
I learned about the mandalorians did we
I feel like I know a little bit more
about the Mandalorian culture
yeah
it was confusing but
I do feel like I'll know a little bit
more
especially nowadays there's two to two
factions there's one that take the
helmets off and there's now what and
obviously the the proper mandalorians
who don't take their helmets off
like
I don't know
I I am a general fan I I I went into
Mandalore and not knowing anything about
mandalorians yeah and I know
a bit more than I did before so yes I
think I know a little bit more
yeah okay you do know more because
particularly the Younglings thing
well
I'm I'm really glad Matt just said that
because I am the exact opposite there
there's
30 40 50 Mandalorian sects and like
different parts and we we combine two
into a back Mandalore I wanted to see 13
14 15 come back together and then at the
end or something have 5 10 12 other
groups of Mandalorian have another Fleet
come in that was there's
oh no no no there's a lot of man like in
Rebels that's going on right now in
Rebels it was a pirate mandalorians as
well
they were just the ones that are left
behind
there's a lot of different factions this
was a whole planet of of and moons of
culture you know and Death Watch was
just one Moon that and now is the
children of the watch that's just one
small little set that was like already
shunned and shoved to the outside of
Mandalorian culture but that's coming
from someone who's
super delved into Star Wars grew up with
it yada yada it's it's ingrained in my
brain I'm glad you said that because
if they would have given us that it's
confusing enough with two factions
already uh it is you need to lay these
ground rules to understand things and I
think season four five six whatever that
is I'm sure we'll get your little
formula groguin din going off of Navarro
and doing whatever but I hope that
formulaic going off in Navarro is to go
sure do some bounty hunting
but find us more mandalorians to to
truly take back Mandalore
our own series isn't she okay
Mandalorian season isn't she or has that
been canceled
that's that's still very rumery it's
just all speculation right now I mean it
would it would make sense Unity
yes it makes sense that there's all
there's so many different factions of
Mandalore uh because of how obviously
it's a whole planet but going into
this season I always just assumed
mandalorians were mandalorians the whole
planet was
like like they are because you've got
the Jedi who are very much they're the
Jedi the Sith are very much there this
Earth so I didn't really
it's naive to think of it but I didn't
really think oh there's going to be
mandalorians that don't really follow
Mandalore
but obviously there is and that is that
is interesting the ones that follow the
way is like literally just that's only
that's like a point 0.05 of mandalorians
like that's that's the smallest group
there is
but they're the most vicious and the
most militaristic and like ancient
mandalore-like which is why they always
pop up and tend to find themselves back
in the story and because they're
interesting and and cool and still and
they're easy to put in live action
because they always in helmets aren't so
there's a few reasons they tend to pop
up
but I these names won't mean anything to
you Aaron will probably know but I I
fully expected Finn Rao and any of the
Rin Clan to pop up and and that have
y'all seen the trailer for Ahsoka did
you see the trailer for Ahsoka Matt no
okay well there is a Mandalorian girl in
there and she's the one with all the
colorful hair in Rebels she has a bunch
of painted uh best car armors her
Mandalorian stuff that's a whole her
family has a whole different thing and
they're really good friends they're
night owls alongside bocatan so they're
part of that Clan ish they're like a
sister Clan essentially
on Mandalorian I'll helmet off the only
helmet ons are the children of the watch
is that like 0.05 percent everybody else
is like yeah yeah you keep your helmet
on all the time
even to sleep you're gonna die early
well I didn't get that kid was not fully
grown his head is gonna grow so don't
make
sure
well the armor would make him a helmet
and then he'd go off somewhere to change
it out of sight
you know the leader got saved by the
fire everyone else went off to where no
one else could see him so they could
take their helmet off eat and then put
it back on yeah because when they say
yeah
never take your home at all in the
presence of another another living being
yeah they don't explain that well do
they they just say like if you're not
really listening and you're a
Mandalorian and you'll be like you never
take your helmet off and you take that
literally
you're not going to live very long yeah
well it's not in the presence of another
living being that's the caveat
that's why uh didn't let um ig-11 spray
him down with the Baghdad in the season
finale of or yeah in the finale of
season one
I can't take my hold off ig's like I'm
not living oh okay
so
there's no Biologicals can see your face
yeah
um my biggest problem with Mandalorian
as a whole is if I swear to God I hear
anybody say this is the way one more
time
I mean not everything is the in way
not everything they're like you know
like no that is not the way
man yeah
there's only one answer to this Jamie
they're the Mandalorian equivalent of
Isis basically they're phonetics
they are the Fanatics that have only got
a very limited vocabulary you know this
is the way it isn't the bloody way
it's not it's not
but I'm hovering over the remove putting
here so
um it's not everything is the way it
just drives me at the wall
um
culture but I do think they could have
done more overall
yeah
yeah teok removed his helmet during this
juices
the old snake in
um I believe that I could do it
I just I I did feel like just say it one
more time a day the other thing is all
right it's a slightly tricky reference
here the mandalorians all have like red
shirts on under their armor because a
lot of them die a lot I mean how is that
how are they still a race
they're just like
most of them died
they propagate by foundlings
mostly well they have to propagate a lot
because they keep running to battle and
it seems that not there is a lot of
people I didn't understand about the
best car armor from from season three so
obviously the the dark Troopers all have
better yeah the mandalorians obviously
all have best car as well they're
shooting each other with assumably
Mandalorian weaponry
but it's best car armor
why would you make your armor like
be able to get damaged by your own
weapons so they're shooting the dark
Troopers the dark Troopers are falling
down very easily not all of them to be
fair yeah no no they make a point of
like shooting behind different weak
points in the armor yeah there's weak
points
they literally shot and then they just
like fall out the fellas well yeah I
mean well they got hit by the spray in
just the right there's vulnerable spots
all over the best yeah
doesn't cover them that much
I mean you look at like Katie sackhoff's
armor there's loads of places you can
shoot
they made a big deal them having basket
that's my point and then they just they
were able to get defeated quite quite
right
that's also best car versus best car you
put best car in a fight with anybody
else like think about Den in season two
with Ahsoka
yeah I mean they can any one of those
people can go toe-to-toe with a Jedi
technically probably not skill base wise
but technically any of them have the
capability of going Toe to Toe well Dave
hey mandalorians have hated the Jedi so
long just about everything they have on
their armor is so they can fight Jedi
hmm
fired wrapping them up you know wrapping
them up flaming them the jet pack so it
goes whistling birds that I can't do
anything about that I mean the jet pack
so they can compete with four sleeps and
four speed I mean it's it's all based on
being able to beat the Jedi who were
their biggest threat in the galaxy
at least
um
well yeah preemptive but I did think
that was a very clever storyline that
that's why they were there that the this
that
an attempt well they're the Rebellion
now aren't they basically so this new
Rebellion that's the alliance
will set themselves up on Mandalore to
get the armor to gun grow and then I
mean they they leaped over the whole
clone thing with um moth Gideon really
quickly though I thought
that that is that was mentioned and he
said oh you know it was mentioned
earlier in the series
cloning to your thing I'm not involved
in that and then they had this whole
thing where he was trying to clone
himself with the force and that was just
like God next
I'm fully expecting him to come back in
season four because it was very much
you you essentially you killed my babies
let me kill you now and then yeah they
were gonna have the force yeah and it
felt it did feel very rushed next the
prevailing theory is that that was a
clone that yeah I was about to say
what's the likelihood y'all think he's a
clone yeah
that's that's that's the prevailing
theories because
when he was watching
um Dan and grogu come towards the
control center he like went out a back
door
before they came in and wrecked all his
clones
and then they got into the area and then
he come in through a complete another
door over here and again didn't have a
mustache and so a lot of people are
thinking that that the real moff Gideon
when he went out the one way he just
jetted and then sent the Clone in from
wherever he was gonna you know go to
safety from and sent him around to do
his business
he was walking the whole time he had
their like live location like yeah
circuitous route
and then ended up back in the other room
I'm sorry cars sorry I'm not sorry they
all benefited more that everyone thinks
he's dead yes
especially since he's obviously planning
on um
at least somewhat rebelling against
thrawn too so it's a very good idea that
he's in hiding right now
Robo Darth Vader looks stupid as well
with his silly little Crown thing
that's how we know you haven't seen
Clone Wars yep I've watched bits of
Clone Wars so do
you recognize who else what other
characters have things like that
well Darth Maul have a little spiky
heavy thing
it wasn't supposed to look like a crime
then they're supposed to look like horns
Darth Maul ruled Mandalore he took it
over from the person that Boca tan
bocatan even though she was a princess
her sister while she ruled Mandalore was
like a pacifist and Boca tan obviously
is like pacifism you know so she joined
death watch the people that turned into
the helmet guys uh and they had the dark
saber they took over Mandalore and then
Darth Maul took over them and became the
leader of Mandalore so Mandalore was
ruled by Darth Maul for a long time and
that's what the sequel Trilogy was going
to originally end up being before Disney
did Disney stuff uh
so that's that's one of those big things
the the armor she always has her little
horns on her head right she very well
might just be she could just be a zabrak
she could be the same species and just
need horns in her Helmet or she very
well might be a maul DeLorean and she's
been playing them the whole time is that
one episode of despise is we only ever
saw one and and
off
yeah I'm talking about moth Gideon's
armor though with the horns though yeah
yeah well one of the theories is that he
at first at some point was either a
follower of maul just in general or
could have been raised Mandalorian yep
it wasn't all DeLorean at the time
after Maul got beat and Mandalore got
purged he went and joined the Empire
because he they specifically said at
some point he was an ISB agent too
and then you know put it put aside his
Mandalorian Heritage because like okay
well the Empire's winning the smart
things to join them join them but never
forget his Heritage and when he finally
got his best car on for himself and his
troops that's why he included the horns
on his helmet too it's because there's
been a long time devotee of Darth Maul
just like um well the rest of the model
orients
so that's a little Easter egg really
okay
um just before we get into the highs and
lows of the series four so ourselves
um the Rotten Tomatoes score for the
season not the fan not the you know
critics one the the the audience score
do you guys know what it is no no should
I take the guess
yeah 65 70 something like that 50.
no that's season three
um
not good and I like to be fair I think
that's pretty fair particularly compared
to season one and two this was not a
good season if television to be honest
for me anyway is it like I say is he
there's a floaty Star Wars fan
um but guys let's go through highs first
what are the what other bits of the
Season that really stand out for you
that you absolutely loved Aaron why
didn't you why don't you go first on
this one what are the highs of the
series for you
um
I loved the fact that they I actually
love the fact they moved Boca town for
it a bit because like Harris I've loved
her character since I watched the Clone
Wars like she's been a badass for years
like years so
um it was cool seeing her do that plus
QVC I was freaking hot
um like I said I'm a two percenter but
um bringing her was cool very cool
um
the injecting of the Mandalorian
day-to-day life even though that was
kind of a filler episode when they had
to go get uh Paz visit Sun back I mean
just the just a little bit more in depth
of their day-to-day
and getting into some specifics was
pretty sweet
um obviously uh Katie's fight with uh ax
woes in order to take over
despite that convenient handoff of the
of the dark saber
um
the uh the old school everyone with the
jetpack battle and the finale was
freaking dope
um the scale of that one was sweet
um
I think the Pirates were pretty fun I
like I mean
mandalorian's always been marketed as
like a space Western so that shootout in
the season premiere was pretty sweet too
like a street shootout with the Pirates
although if they show me another weak
way pirate without it being Hondo onaka
I'm gonna have a fit
[Laughter]
thinking about it I know it's like they
could have brought him into
um the bad batch of using um what's her
name Wanda Sykes is pirate character as
soon as she said yeah
bring Hondo nothing then you give me a
weak way pirate but in the premiere of
the Mandalorian but again not Hondo it's
like he's one of the everyone he's just
about everyone's one of their favorite
characters from clone wars and Rebels oh
he's one of my favorite Star Wars
characters honestly I love Hondo and and
we keep seeing Ugg knots and weak ways
pop up I'm like just cool yeah
episode that was sweet that was probably
one of the most parts of that episode
for me that's one of my highlights for
the season it's not something I would
think about but easily one of my
highlights yeah what's the rest of your
highlights Harris
um
well how many ugnots were there
those uh no uh that
everything everything Aaron said because
those were honestly kind of the best
parts uh
the the second episode I just really
enjoyed uh the the the minds Mandalore I
mean I I I'm a Sci-Fi guy all day and
every day but a little Lord of the Rings
in there oh my God I'm a happy camper I
got I got an elder scroll around me
right now I like my fantasy you know so
I mine's a Mandalore hit it right where
I wanted it to hit it that was like a
super sweet that was space fantasy
Perfection for me uh
the surrounding episodes making that
make sense that's a different discussion
but I really liked uh episode two and I
I liked all the high points that Aaron
talked about and then freaking up knots
just come on
come on I love me some of them what did
you like the other nuts that's the
that's the question
I have spoken
okay
um how about you Matt what did you as
like say is an outside like me what did
what was your highest
I actually like the action scenes
that's literally what I watch it for
like the fight scenes but that thing
that thing like you said that everyone's
on the jet pack yeah that was great I
loved it
um
the the thing with the uh was was the
thing with the Pirates and they crashed
the pirate ship in this season
yeah I really like that I really like
that the pattern stuff was cool yeah
I like Robo as well
every five minutes a Mandalorian is
tripping over a massive dinosaur that's
what I thought it was a bit strange but
go and say what else anything else uh
yeah Robo grogu but you hate him so
um
Darth Vader both bit stupid if the ugnas
don't take the cake the end zelen does
just
are just fun that was one of the few
redeeming qualities the rise of
Skywalker for me I'd love Baboo
no squeezy I love that
okay
for me the highs were the same as human
the the final episode was great with the
with the battle with the in the jetpack
battle and everything that was brilliant
um
that's it uh Casey suck off
um she was unbelievable you couldn't
pick it they'd have had to have like
genetically engineered somebody to do
that part it would look like
she's just she's just perfect for the
role
can period She voiced her clone wars and
Rebels and now she's her in live action
she is
yeah
she's had the characters
18 years huh it's a perfect customer
absolutely diabolically perfect but I am
so I love that
um okay so we don't like talking
negatively too much on here but you know
it's fun and I yeah so
um
go on Aaron you we'll go around again
same route neck downside anything that
you thought yeah
buckle up
um
well first of all obviously the
obviously the writing was all over the
place and
to me that's that's mostly down to
politics and Kathy pissing John off and
a couple other things
um so I don't blame John completely for
that
um yeah just the I mean it was cool to
find out what happened to Pershing I
guess but not in a 40-minute
like middle of a 50 minute episode where
I got 10 minutes of what the show is
actually about and then all that crap
and then 10 minutes of more what the
show is actually about
so that was kind of a bummer
um again the the cramming in of all the
Rangers of the Republic storyline made
it super awkward
um
no offense to Jack Black and lizzo but
again that whole segment of that episode
was a complete freaking waste of time
for me I mean if you're gonna throw in a
fun little Cameo filler episode like
that do it in episode two or three not
episode six out of eight there was more
of the timing of that one that got that
gotten under my skin than the actual
episode itself although it was still
mostly a waste of time anyway no I got
that we were supposed to be getting to
the business end of the season and they
have this weird filler episode I mean I
get that here yep
um
yeah just just the way the just the way
the story ended up playing out and just
all the excess filler and uh
I wasn't a lot of people out there got
pissed off by by Bo getting the dark
saber on that Tech on that technicality
that didn't bother me too much
um
it wasn't essentially the whole Elder
one document isn't it with uh Harry
Potter it's exactly basically the same
sort of thing oh yeah totally
totally the same sort of thing but um
yeah just a lot of it a lot of it
basically comes down to the writing and
the way they put the show together it
was just awkward
um all over the place
and
like when they when they did get to the
story they just you know it was cool but
they did that was the story ended up
being underdone because they overdid all
the other [__]
stuff yeah
that was my big thing about it mostly
negatives Paris
uh
uh yeah all the Rangers the new Republic
stuff I agree with their uh that that
could have been just because because it
just feels Frankenstein it feels
Frankenstein at the end of the day uh
instead of
methodically put together it just feels
like okay we we got what we got you know
uh for for better and worse
um Whatchamacallit uh
uh I'd also say that the Jack Black and
lizzo episode
but no no for for different reasons um
well for the same reason for the timing
uh it didn't belong in the part of the
Season where it was
but
see I wouldn't just give me 10 episodes
and have one of them be Jack Black and
lizzo and and be on that planet let Jack
Black do most of the talk and all that
lizzo's just not an actress okay if you
want to have a cool Cameo have a cool
Cameo but relegate it to a cameo and not
a part in the episode you could have had
lizzo be like the main Queen even though
Jack Black's her King it's obvious that
he kind of was like welcomed to the
planet you know and it was really
lizzo's have her sit on a throne instead
of throwing Billiards and and Polo in
the middle of a freaking Square have her
sit on a throne and like give give the
quest and then say Oh great Jack Black
let him do his thing put him more
pivotal in the episode but the thing
that got me about that episode is
you use Christopher freaking Lloyd and
put him in with this Count Dooku like
that should have been its entire episode
that should have been an episode I don't
that could have been a spin-off series
and I would have been happy uh yeah it
was a bit
that was the best part of the three
cameos uh story-wise and just
Jack Black acted fine uh those are not
amazing actress that's why you relegate
her to a cameo but I think Christopher
Lloyd did his part the best and any any
Count Dooku's one of my favorite
characters
and he's my individual favorite hero and
villain it doesn't matter who asked the
question that's my answer for both for
Star Wars characters he's my favorite
Star Wars character in general and he
literally he's the only person that's
ever led a legitimately like
wholeheartedly good
side not wholeheartedly good uh because
but he was convinced to do the bad that
he did in a way uh and he did do it
willingly at a certain point but he's
the most anti-hero actual hero
separatists were really the good guys at
the end of the day kind of thing and and
that I love seeing
because it we dive into all the space
politics without forgetting like hey
there were people that were like just
trying to do good for themselves you
know that's it
yeah okay not a few times negatives
some of it was boring
there are episodes that didn't need to
exist
that's basically it some of it was born
I mean that I'm not a mega fan like
these two so I can't pick outs like this
is this didn't like meet my expectations
here and there but
I think just
the fact that I I wasn't invested Within
I've done the first couple of episodes
some that's you know the festivals were
good
I think I think after
what episode was it with the flying the
flying thing
three or four yeah three and four or
four and five one of the two
hmm yeah
after they cut to uh
and then went to the covert in episode
three yeah
yeah I I I'm it was it was episode one
actually at the end of episode one
is when I I felt the formula the
formulaic like
I I I I felt it
not not the force felt it I I physically
felt it
all we got to do is see it open its eye
twice
yeah what the crap dude yeah I don't
give me the whole thing and not bring
the mythosaur out
um I almost forgot about that but yeah
the myth is sword being just teased into
nothing but there was time for another
miscellaneous giant creature to pop out
from under the you know like okay on
their way to uh the great Forge which
turns out to be Gideon's base we had to
have another random next door it's next
door to get into space wasn't it they
were they were base adjacent yeah when
you have to go through a door to the
side yeah
completely underutilized the mythosaur
negatives to me let's think Robo grogu
stupid Robo Darth Vader was stupid the
um dark the dark saber looks stupid
um not anymore it's broken it was broken
it was boring in places there was too
many episodes the whole
um Imperial
um every thingy Center where the
rehabilitation center yeah that that
storyline went on for ages and didn't go
anywhere
um and it was stupid
um that whole character from
um what we've seen before this was it
Boba Fett watching before this we saw as
a bad guy now
um
it's she didn't go anywhere you becoming
the woman the woman who put the guide in
chair essentially yes yeah
go anyway
um yeah there was there was probably
more Filler episodes in this season than
there were actually like story episodes
but if you're gonna do a series like
this
and it's only eight eight episodes I
could say that should be one story and
it should have enough story to film that
they had at least four episodes that
were just with nothing to do with the
overall story of the season and
but they they but they weren't for
anything one of them was to go and build
Robo grogu he could have done that with
anything it didn't it didn't need to be
why did it have to be that robot but he
went outside so far out of his way to
get that specific
robot that again he wanted ig11 so badly
he even wanted he wanted like his memory
chips and everything back and in the end
didn't get him like so what was the
point exactly it was irrelevant it was
like three episodes of the season was
completely irrelevant yeah go anyway and
the episode with the bloody pterodactyl
thing and the hot that whole episode was
stupid
and a complete waste of time and it made
absolutely no logical sense they cocky
coughed up that youngling that Bloody
pterodactyl thing and the youngling was
fine and I'm sorry that's not how
anything works
um I just it's just it just blew my mind
how idiotic parts of the Season were and
I actually quite liked other bits but
the bits I hated I properly was like
this is no that's not even it's not even
that I hated him I didn't dislike them I
was completely indifferent to them I was
completely now which I to me is a worse
crime in sci-fi that I didn't care in
the slightest it's just so forgettable
but the bits of it were stupid and it's
such a shame because seasons one and two
were brilliant it was so good they were
just like some of the best Star Wars for
me I honestly I think the Star Wars TV
in the last five years has been way
better than the movies for a long time
um and
it's just it's just a shame that
they've gone this
the problem was like say it's not that
it was it just wandered so randomly all
the way through the season just oh what
are they gonna do next two [__] those
because they're just gonna
wonder and that was something and that's
my whole feeling of the series really
was wandering
for the last episode
I just wish they'd done a bit more of
that there are certain story lines like
like you said Harris the whole thing
with Christopher and Lloyd and that
whole storyline which was two minutes in
the actual episode I'm thinking I'd have
loved to have seen that sort of like
more intertwined through the through the
series and it wouldn't make that episode
make more it would have made the episode
more relevant and the more about the
separatists and more about all that and
that was like and it would have made
Christopher Lloyd's part much more
important but instead it was just like a
like an anecdote yeah like just it was a
wasted opportunity so you've given me
two thoughts here uh the first one is
hopefully like like I said earlier it
took legitimately three years three
seasons worth of material for people to
love the Ahsoka character and whenever
they loved the Ahsoka character it went
from like oh this character is annoying
why the hell she keep popping up like we
just want Anakin Obi-Wan and like Yoda
like why do we keep getting this random
character
by the ark that she turns into like
Ahsoka she's one of the best Star Wars
characters ever written and of course
George's seal of approval was given and
he helped formulate her alongside Dave
yada yada so I'm hoping
with with Dave at the helm
even if we don't love this season right
now a lot of the things that don't make
sense now will make sense in three years
we'll make sense in four years because
that's just kind of the way he rolls
but back to back to exactly what you
were just saying was
one of the big things that people want
the mandalorians to do differently and
have wanted to do differently since
season one is we keep getting super
freaking short episodes
so with those short episodes that people
want more things explained but with the
short episodes we keep getting filler
what are y'all thinking what do y'all
think about that because we we want more
episodes where we can dive into Star
Wars and understand what we're thinking
about and and watching instead of just
action action boom boom uh put something
fun in there have something good for the
general public and then call it Star
Wars because that's kind of what it
feels obviously it's formulaic but
do we run into the issue of more filler
with more time or does that allow the
writer's room to flesh it out because
then they're thinking about it
differently
my question
if uh if they're doing their if they're
writing well it shouldn't be a problem
to go even 10 episodes or eight or even
keep it at eight but go like you know 55
to 60 Minutes on each and every one of
them I mean there's
there is so much lore and even Theory
out there that they could draw on even
though Kathy said there's no Source
material
um
so there's there's
an insane amount of
EU material now Legends material that
they can draw on and which Dave is
starting to do thank God a little bit a
little bit yep a little bit by little
bit he's bringing Legends into Canon but
um yeah it would not be hard to go 8 55
or a longer minute episodes
it shouldn't be a problem for any writer
worth his or her chops at all
um
let me just but I can't
so my internet seems to be a bit dodgy
at the moment okay so it's apologize
about that but Matt you got any thoughts
before we head off
no
[Laughter]
that was the problem with me it was just
disappointing
that's the problem I had it was just
really disappointing and I can show you
when they make stupid mistakes and
things like this I just I find it
frustrating but very quickly then one
last question
is the future of Star Wars
safe
Marvel I'm not sure Star Wars
see if you would have asked that same
question two months ago three months ago
five months ago a year ago I would have
put Marvel over Star Wars honestly but
just after the last couple projects I
think Star Wars is still safer than
Marvel
specifically for being not to say
Marvel's not beloved by people because
it is beloved by people but Star Wars we
all know just holds a special spot in in
pop culture in the world and that I
think will allow it to weather more than
Marvel's able to because even even with
formulaic stuff that we're talking about
in season three of a TV show
that's one season the last thing that we
got besides that was bad batch which
people were like oh okay and then it
finished and they were like oh my God
give us more bad [__]
oh yeah easily season two of bad
Bachelors oh and season three is gonna
be the end like that pissed me off I
went five seconds I want I won seven
seasons give me another clone wars
anything tales of the Jedi was before
that visions and door
boom boom boom Star Wars is doing fine I
I I there's there's definitely some
stuff going on
but at the end of the day it's fine
Marvel is in much more of a I think a
hard flung future because Kevin [__] at
this Point's like hey
I I don't see why he stays I'll be
legitimately honest I don't see why
Kevin feige is still there besides like
just brand loyalty and and wanting to
finish something that he started but he
already finished what he started really
this is a whole new thing with whole new
producers whole new teams you have four
other teams that you're trying to put on
screen that alone requires like four to
eight ten twelve teams of people to put
one new team of people on to
the screen uh I think Marvel's in a much
much much dire uh much more dire era
than Star Wars is and I think that's
solely because in in Star Wars only wins
because it is Star Wars that's the only
thing like it should be in just as dire
uh straights because although the TV
shows have been great
it's not as not not a whole bunch of
people watch Andor I still think Andor
may be one of the best Star Wars things
if not the best Star Wars thing
on the back of what you've just said
the reason Star Wars is probably going
to endure
over Marvel
is
there's at least 20 000 years of history
now that we know there's 20 20 000 Year
movie coming out
and with Styles because it was set it's
basically set in the past as it is
you can have these stories at any point
along that timeline it doesn't matter
yeah so you can literally have
we we've had essentially the movies
we've let's talk about movies the movies
we've had have always been within what a
100 200 year period essentially
maybe but there's going to be there's
going to be a load of stuff has happened
way after that but there's stuff that's
happened way before that that they
haven't even delved into movie-wise and
TV show wise and maybe they have in the
in the in the cartoons but not like in
live action yeah kind of thing so that's
they've got so much they could do and I
think that's why it will endure because
they've got so much the I know Legends
isn't Canon anymore but if they if they
make it Canon because they've every
right they can do it's still their
property they can just make pick and
choose parts of it make it Canon
it'll
it'll it'll go on for a really long time
because there's so much oh yeah and it's
it's even though like we've talked about
it it can be a little confusing
just but but when it comes to Star Wars
the only thing that's confusing is is
the timeline because if you just watch
or wait a little bit you're gonna get
the culture explanation you're going to
get the explanation here you're gonna do
that
with Marvel
hey we're a Sci-Fi channel we love our
sci-fi Concepts we sci-fi is hails King
yes
but the Multiverse is just not not good
for the general public as as much as I
love the concept it it it's real like
that's a legitimate thing in physics
like we we know this exists it it
shouldn't be something that's so crazy
for all of us to comprehend but it's not
easy to comprehend and that is hard to
show to your general public and like
like you just said we have all of
Earth's history to put into the Marvel
universe as well but it's a lot more
like you have to be a lot more precise
when you do that because that character
might still be alive might come back
later
and it affects things and obviously
we're talking about rights Marvel one of
the reasons Marvel
may have trouble enduring is because of
how long it took to get Fantastic Four
how long it took to get X-Men now we're
just getting Namor ish or do we have
Hulk kind of maybe ish who knows
completely yet they're still Sony yeah
and and and and and that is no matter
how confusing Star Wars ever gets
timeline wise because Star Trek is ten
times as confusing timeline wise I'm
just saying uh but
it doesn't matter if it's confusing
um really it's confusing with what we've
had so far because they've been
not shoehorned in but the the stories
that have happened in between stories
that we already know but if they make a
story that's completely separate it's
still Star Wars but it's like let's say
20 000 years in the past
essentially is a new timeline it's not
confusing because it's so far separated
I don't think audiences would be
confused about that at all yeah
the thing is is that the Multiverse idea
and it is only theoretical it's not it's
a matter it's one of those things that's
mathematically true but probably isn't
in
realistically but it's not just that
it's a difficult concept to explain or
to understand it's a difficult concept
to present on a screen the quantum Realm
looks stupid in the new in the new
Ant-Man movie it just doesn't work it's
like a cartoon it doesn't work it's
better they cost 200 million dollars to
make it and they lost a crapload again
it's like the fourth movie in a row
that's just been not good and but the
storyline they're right in Marvel is
wandering at the moment but Star Wars is
as well they're both really wandering
they but they could always
it does feel like with Star Wars though
they've they've brought in these new
people and everything they've grabbed it
by the Scruff of the neck and they've
sort of gone right we've lost our way
here a little bit this this isn't the
way we need to get back to the way so oh
this is the way and that's what this
team should've done so I'm hoping
they've realized
and they're dragging it back but we
won't know
if it's worked or not for probably 12 to
18 months and then we'll I think we'll
know whether it's whether they've got it
back to the right direction
but we're Marvel I can't see them even
trying to do that
they just don't seem to be trying
they seem to think that where the way
they're going it's all planned out let's
keep going and I'm telling you what the
movies are rubbish at the moment
yeah Marvel is in trouble
they peaked they peaked uh end game and
they can't reach that that level of
I don't know awesome again
but they should have gone back to the
realism side of things right so they
started off with Iron Man which is
realistic and you know I still have
money in the nine suit which isn't
realistic but you know what I mean it
felt more real and then they got more
and more extraordinary but they I always
said Marvel genius are keeping it just
this side is silly
but they've forgotten how to do it and
they've just wondered they're just
dancing all over that silly line now and
a lot of this stuff is silly but when
they got to that extreme it got
massively extraordinary you know with
um with the end of the the Thanos
storyline they should have gone it back
then they should have gone it right back
and gone right now we need a couple of
Iron Man movies again not literally Iron
Man movies but not realistic movies
let's drag it all right back and then we
need to build up to another
extraordinary you know Avengers movie
eventually but they just didn't
they keep trying to end game again and
it doesn't work it's not working
Spider-Man was a good next movie after
that because it did kind of bridge the
gap between cool concept
keep it keep it localized and focused uh
uh if they would have kept it more
street level I think would have made
more sense but okay so you made me think
that needs to bring it back is the the
best smartphone movie ever to come out
yeah like jump never oh
yeah
I actually feel the opposite I have more
confidence in Marvel's future than I do
in Star Wars honestly
um one [__] greater than Kathleen and
any day of the week twice on Sunday
blindfolded with his hands tied mind is
back in a jail cell shoved in a barrel
um specific feels like you've done that
to somebody
um number one Marvel actually is
starting to spend money on writers
unlike they did basically for all of
phase four which is mostly why phase
four was booty cheeks for the most part
because they were given a lot of unknown
writers a lot of chances but now they've
hired um
I can't remember their names but they've
they've just they just got a new writer
for blade they just got a new writer for
the Thunderbolts
um a really good writer for Fantastic
Four so they're spending money on
writers again so basically they've done
the um you know how to say we've made
[__] booty cheeks movies without
saying we've made [__] booty cheeks
movies they're spending money on writers
which is what they need to do because
they're writing's been and they need to
spend money on special effects as well
because they've got a team well see
that's a whole other thing Victoria
Alonso was head of the VFX for like uh
since 21. so that's a lot of the reason
why they booted her she she was the uh
one of the main reasons why contact
Mania uh didn't look as good she
allocated a bunch of money to Black
Panther right yeah well they they make
sense like people at the VFX house that
was working on quantumania literally
said they had a massive epic battle
scene
for quantumania that they got pulled off
of and could not finish
so they could um tighten up the effects
on um wakanda forever and you know who
uh was one of the people on that scene
right
the the evil girl from uh season three
of Mandalorian she was the one of the
main fighters in quantumania she was
like their person that they hired to
like help I don't know oh yeah but she
was one of their like main martial
artists in quantumania the the Imperial
lady that lobotomized Pershing and
Mandarin season three okay yeah
but yeah so
um
and Star Wars isn't really making any
kind of moves like that to me I mean
they had a really good concept of little
off and then Kathy just keeps sticking
her fingers and stuff she doesn't she
needs to just be sent back in her office
and managing the money that's all she
needs to be doing
um I got a question for you then before
we before we head off because there was
a big rumor going around at the moment
because you mentioned Fantastic Four
oh yeah at the moment you know it's
wherever I'm going with this that
they're going to cast the thing as a
lady and me na Kunis might get the part
that's the that's the room and it's
going around at the moment
um
do we care
it's not a good idea it's just a
different character though isn't it
well it depends if they're gonna make
her Bonnie Grimm that's a problem now
there is an actual separate
so if they want to include her instead
of Ben I think that'd be also silly but
not as silly as turning Ben Grimm into
Bonnie ground
um like I have absolutely no problem
with you know with inclusion I'm fairly
Progressive when it comes to that kind
of stuff but there's also certain things
you don't screw with and the first
family of Marvel is one of them
I don't think gender swapping for the
sake of gender swapping uh is
necessarily a good idea uh I mean
honestly don't don't replace Ben with
female BEN
um but if it's the actual if it's the
other character
yeah fine that's like because it's a
different character it's not like you've
replaced Ben with female BEN you you
have a female character and you've cast
a female for that female character and
that's that's absolutely fine
that's less of a bad idea but I mean
just in general you need to leave the
Fantastic Four as
read Johnny Sue and Ben
yeah
what do you think well I honestly don't
think it's gonna happen though
after this kind of backlash they've
gotten over just the last couple days
online I I definitely don't think it
happened will happen if if they were to
do it I I'm with
I don't know what y'all matinearen on on
this one uh
I would I would I would much prefer to
have been Grim it just makes more sense
but if they were to do it I I would just
toss Michael Chiklis in a wig or or put
a really Butchy kind of lady on there
for the thing why would it be my Myla
why would it be Mila Kunis is the first
thing just for like
I mean if if she's relegated to a voice
role the only thing I'm gonna be
thinking about next exactly you can't no
and if if she's just a voice Roll All
I'm going to be thinking about is Meg of
Family Guy as the thing you know that's
it shut up
you know I just I I wish uh they they'd
keep it just normal there is a she thing
put she thing in there of course
but then again I don't think Mila Kunis
is right for that who I don't know how
that casting idea ever even happened
maybe they just toss it online started
off as possibly Mila for Sue
and then somehow morphed into the Sioux
or the thing now like they're
considering her for both and then like
uh it's it sounds like the Creator's
just gone I want somebody Jewish for the
thing character and I don't care if it's
a boy or a girl as long as it's Jewish
as long as he or she's Jewish well I
mean meal is mostly I mean she's I think
she you know obviously she's probably
one of you know the white juices that
you say but she's Ukrainian for the most
part yeah she's Russian Ukrainian yeah
I don't know what her ethnic background
is but I assume she's Jewish or it
wouldn't make sense at least in some
part yeah on her mother's side it has to
be an account
ethnicity swapping and things like this
generally speaking because we're talking
about fictional characters and in Marvel
in particular there's so much material
there they've done every version of
every character we've got how many
Captain Americas have we have for about
two or three female Captain America's
two or three different male we've had
black ones but it's you know they've
done every version of everything on the
in the comments there's a little Captain
Britain Council yeah yeah exactly so he
doesn't bother me the people go what is
woke no that's Canon is no in Marvel
they've got Canon for everything so it's
like no Bob my life performance that I'm
kind of with you guys I think it'll be
stupid it's not that it's it's not that
it's I think and then do they look
She-Hulk there was a steaming pile of
crap not because of She-Hulk I actually
thought the actress was brilliant I
thought that her character was great it
was very badly written but the worst
crime is actually when you watch the
last episode you realize you've just
watched eight hours is that are
completely irrelevant because it didn't
go anywhere
so it was stupid but it wasn't stupid I
actually would love to see She-Hulk in
other stuff I'm angry
um if they do it right
I have no confidence in Marvel at the
moment to do anything right I honestly
think they've they've really lost their
way at the moment and they need to
Fantastic Four is one of the ones for so
that's another reason I kind of doubt
yeah there's too much veracity to the
Mila Kunis has the thing is it still
shackman directing Aaron I believe so
okay
but blade for me is a good example of
swell that they need to bring they need
the blade needs to be street level they
need to be a Spider-Man type style thing
and not do
a big one's supposed to be pretty street
level
yeah
um which would be awesome super awesome
um obviously they're going they're going
more street level on Disney plus with uh
Daredevil they're bringing um they're
double born again
Castle into that they've already
confirmed burn Falls coming back as
Punisher for that
um
got something good that saying that is
actually going to be R-rated or or
they're not going to make it 12a which I
think is important it's the best bits of
Daredevil when he was you know
putting someone's head through something
what was the next movie that's supposed
to be R-rated other than Deadpool that
like just hit the news uh what wasn't it
blade
yeah
definitely is going to be R-rated
sorry just last question then we really
do have to wrap it up but it's it's
Marvel's biggest problem but there's
just been too much Marvel
that they've been ocean they're trying
to do too much there's been too much bad
Marvel
I have bad I have mid comic book
um product fatigue if it was all
slapping the way it should have been yes
John Bernthal Kerry
um if it'd been slapping the way it all
should there would be no fatigue but the
problem is is the writing has been crap
um they're they're utilizing the
characters completely wrong they're
writing them super shallow
um the stories just go all over the
place
um and again there's also all the behind
the scenes crap with um feige basically
taking phase four off probably to
concentrate on phase five and six I
would assume and just letting his
creatives do whatever the hell they want
and we saw how that went which is why
they're hiring writers and why he has
gone already gone into a couple
different writers rooms are like no
because the Thunderbolts has been
completely redone because of him he
walked in like he walked into that
writer's room's like nope small idea
small idea small idea we're going Red
Hulk
we're going you know Century all that
good stuff
uh yes Harrison Ford is Thunderbolt Ross
that is going to be so sweet but yeah no
Marvel's Marvel is making obvious moves
to right the ship if you're if you're
looking
um yeah I don't other outside of Ahsoka
and um Dave's movie and the dawn of the
Jedi movie I don't see Star Wars making
any kind of moves to
become more of a four-quarter product
the way it used to be it Marvel five
years ago blade would be enough Cinemas
probably this summer but they yeah I
think you're right they have realized
we're going the wrong way here we need
to drag this back we need the right
people we need the right writers let's
just let's not do if it's not right I
think they're on either their third
right or for blade or they brought this
dude into co-write with the dude they
brought in he's doing a rewrite he's not
doing a total
yeah regardless though they got a big
name they brought in a big name for that
and they got the dude for beef for uh
Thunderbolts yeah yeah big names all
right guys look we've gone over an hour
and a half which we haven't done in a
live streaming ages
Aaron it's Matt's fault probably
Matt everything's your fault mate
um but we love you for it so um let's
call it an evening because I'm really
hungry and um
as well my kids have just been out and
they've had McDonald's and I'm proper
jealous
McDonald's
it's been amazing really good internet
conversation and most of it I didn't
understand but you know
um I'll I'll watch it back and I'll
Google and I'll try to catch up oh there
were moments where my eyes totally
glazed over especially when Harris and
uh Aaron were talking of talking about
um star warsy stuff
[Laughter]
kind of like
really fascinating uh next week we're
playing a game of fantasy
um streaming Channel Executives so we
are taking a chance oh Harris what did
you want to pick
Matt's got Netflix
are we just doing the top three or what
just the top three so you've got Amazon
or Disney who do you want uh yeah I know
you want Amazon take it
so I am the new chief executive of
Amazon Prime Matthew is the new chief
executive of Netflix and Harris is the
new chief executive of Disney plus
you are allowed to share your passwords
again yeah
right maybe it's actually too bad do
that as well and um my first order of
business I'm gonna get rid of all of
these sub channels that cost five pounds
each we're just gonna have one
everything's gonna be absorbed actually
remember that just just yeah completely
fantasy you're in charge what you want
to do and that's our video next week
guys so we'll have a bit of a giggle
with that it's not going to be an N when
it pops up it's going to be an m
[Laughter]
and then um and I think it's that as
well we're gonna like say we're gonna
fix this stuff so all the streamers
channels are struggling we saw it we've
sorted Stargate out for him now we're
just gonna sort everything else out so
just a bit of fun and how many I want to
get a running pool and how many times
Stargate gets mentioned
because I think it's gonna be quite a
lot so um but guys thank you so much uh
Aaron really really appreciate you um
attending
um
letting me attend
yeah well you're very welcome um come
back whenever you want you're super
interested well thank you
you have lots to say it's great yeah
absolutely really good um the live video
we did on your channel was brilliant as
well I really enjoyed it yeah
you lasted like way longer than I
thought you were gonna for like your
time when we started that's not that's
not my wife that's I thought you were I
thought you were going to be good for
maybe like an hour you ended up going a
little bit over an hour and a half with
me which was because it was good for you
as it was for me
write me out to Temp now that's why I
said to that
um Harris again thank you so so much sir
I really really appreciate every week
always y'all go support Jay
go go to sidetrack.com
and buy your sleeping Jack of yeah buy
your t-shirts and your hats and all that
sort of thing because it helps me and
the wife my wife loves this channel now
she used to moan but as soon as I bought
her a nice pair of shoes god damn it
because James turned oh yes I gotta I
got her on board she actually says go
are you going to work it's even and she
means this
but anyway thank you sir
we'll see you all really really soon
bye-bye
bye
[Music]